very strange stuff is happening at the
White House on the same day that Isis
claimed responsibility for a deadly
attack in Syria which killed a total of
four people including two American
servicemembers and injured three others
vice president Mike Pence declared
victory over Isis and simultaneously
said we're getting out of Syria and
we're going to stick out the fight how
all of this stuff can be true I have no
idea this is sort of another one of
those
mission accomplished moments remember
when George W Bush had won on the deck
of an aircraft carrier which was
followed by 5,000 American servicemember
deaths in Iraq not exactly mission
accomplished
pence yesterday was at the global Chiefs
mission conference at the US State
Department listen to what he said thanks
to the leadership of this commander in
chief and the courage and sacrifice of
our armed forces we're now actually able
to begin to hand off the fight against
Isis in Syria to our coalition partners
and we are bringing our troops home the
caliphate has crumbled and isis has been
defeated yeah not a particularly
confident teleprompter read from Mike
Pence there and the muted applause
doesn't make it sound too much better
but the real problem is the facts which
is that we had an attack in Syria
yesterday for which Isis claimed
responsibility for people died three
people injured two of the four Dead
Americans servicemembers and as far as
what we know right now a suicide bomber
with an explosive vest matching the mo
of Isis Isis claiming responsibility
it's certainly not a good look to be
bragging about the defeat of Isis on the
same day that you have to tell the
families of servicemembers that at least
initially it appears as though Isis has
actually killed their loved ones and of
course you can defend this by saying
pence didn't know that that had taken
place at the time that he gave this
speech very difficult to imagine we
don't know exactly what pence knew and
when he knew it but the military
operation confirmed the deaths of these
servicemembers hours before pence spoke
they had issued a statement about it
and pence doesn't even mention it here
and he could have at least said
something like despite the tragic deaths
in Syria today of our valued
servicemembers we are almost there with
defeating Isis or something it may not
even have been true but it at least
would have implied a little bit more
empathy and decorum than what Mike Pence
did now even weirder than what we just
saw if you can imagine it is that later
in the same speech pence says that we
are getting out but also that we're
staying in the fight I mean it just
makes no sense take a listen to it now
we'll stay in the region and we'll stay
in the fight to ensure that Isis does
not rear its ugly head again we will we
will protect the gains that our soldiers
and our coalition partners have secured
but this president is often spoken about
his his desire to bring an end to
endless wars in America the ability to
push our troops home so we're going to
end endless wars but we're also going to
stay in the fight
but we're leaving but we're not leaving
I thought the whole point was that we
weren't staying in the fight this is
doublespeak the likes of which we would
be used to reading in a George Orwell
novel we defeated Isis but I won't
mention that Isis killed four people
today but we're leaving and getting out
of endless wars like Trump said but
we're staying in the fight for as long
as we need to stay in the fight but
Trump is against endless wars sort of
brilliant in a weird way take every side
of every issue let fox news edit out the
contradictions for the narrative that
they spoon-feed their audience let it
get figured out later by right-wing
media or just not at all and you're on
record as having taken every position on
multiple sides of an issue and within 20
seconds what this leads to is a vice
president saying both that we're
bringing troops home and we're staying
in the fight is this considered
leadership is this considered resolved
by the trumpet and depending on who's
speaking and what's more advantageous
Isis both has and has not been defeated
if you listen to what Mike pens and
others are saying we're justifying
leaving Syria by saying Isis has been
defeated but if we want to show how big
and strong and committed
Trump is we're saying we finished this
job and we're going to stay as long as
it takes it sort of doesn't even matter
because the lies are going unchecked and
with no real consequences so what's the
disadvantage to just taking every
position on all of these issues send me
your thoughts what the hell was Mike
Pence talking about I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show if you love learning
new things you probably want to check
this out the David Pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video